invité politique de guillaume durand sur
radio classique et par les premières à
l'impression bonjour france avait encore
une fois on a l'impression qu'il est un
peu hors sol françois hollande
en tout cas la posture il est choisi
voilà la posture qu'il a choisie est une
posture qui ne peut que rencontrer le le
scepticisme d'abord ironique et puis
après on est fâché des français quand
vous pensez que le thème de la réunion
électorale de lundi c'était ça va mieux
à l'école quand vous êtes enseignant et
que vous voyez toutes les difficultés
qui sont très lourdes et qui ne tiennent
pas seulement au poste le
l'incompréhension que le gouvernement a
manifesté à l'égard de l'école au fond à
l'égard de tous ceux qui la font et de
tous ceux qui la portent et de tous ceux
qui subissent des échecs
c'est comme une provocation par le sur
les haies et pour beaucoup d'entre eux
c'est comme une gifle sur les cordes par
des mois on va y revenir je vais
simplement con con qu'on fasse ça dans
l'ordre dès qu'on termine sur françois
hollande ce qui est assez bizarre c'est
que dans le magazine société manuel
valls qui en général est toujours
comment peut-on dire pub nas avait l'air
de dire aussi qu'un certain nombre
d'erreurs avait été fait là rien dans
cette réunion une terre du rond-point
pour commémorer donc les 80 ans du front
populaire c'est-à-dire pas la moindre
parenthèses par la moindre manière de
considérer que les choses ont peut être
été ratée le carême une nature
particulière enfin moi je suis pas un
adepte de de la compétition public et de
la contrition à perpétuité parce que je
pense qu'il ya des incidents dans la
région oui mais ceci est autre chose
ce que vous dénoncez c'est que je
démontrais résout alors à la question
que vous posez elle porte non pas sur un
discours mais sur l'ignorance de la
réalité et le en effet le nombre de
d'incidents déchets que de situations
insupportables que les français voient
sous leurs yeux et vivent dans leur vie
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinairement
frappant et même d' extraordinairement
choquant et moi je crois pas du tout
qu'une campagne aussi méthode couet
puisse avoir la moindre chance de
convaincre les français que penser
françois hollande sera au deuxième tour
et couvet ce que je pense depuis
longtemps que françois hollande a perdu
le crédit qui lui était fait pour ces
cinq années et donc ses chances de
réélection parce qu'il a refusé
où il n'a pas su assumer la fonction qui
devait être la sienne la fonction de
président de la république c'est à dire
de quelqu'un qui montre le chemin est en
phase avec le peuple qui l'a élu et
dessinent un horizon il s'est dérobé
perpétuellement à ce devoir là pour une
raison que tout le monde voit bien c'est
qu'il ne fallait pas fâché sa majorité
ou une partie de sa majorité or un
président de la république ne doit pas
vivre avec l'idée d'une majorité c'est
pas son travail
ça c'est le travail du premier ministre
le président de la république qui doit
vivre avec l'idée d'un peuple tout
entier réuni par d'un peuple coupée
entre majorité et opposition droite et
gauche et à l'intérieur de la gauche
entre une certaine gauche et une autre
laurent berger qui a soutenu au départ
enfin qui a soutenu en partie donc le
projet de loi les conneries cad en
discussion au parlement
et quand même très très critique ce
matin dans le figaro il parle du
désordre dans la rue encore des
manifestations à nantes avec des
interpellations les blessés parmi les
forces de l'ordre il dit est absolument
aucun cap on n'exprime pas aux français
exactement où on va ni sur le plan
économique ni sur le plan évidemment
politique c'est quand même le
réquisitoire le plus violent d'une sorte
d' allié idéologique de la gauche
alors vous allez je vais vous répéter
des choses que j'ai déjà dit à votre
micro il ya une chose qui est
extraordinairement frappante cette loi
telle connerie c'est une loi
emblématique de la dernière partie de ce
quinquennat une loi en benatiq de la
dernière partie d'une vente a donc une
sorte de tombeaux d'après est le seul
autre ollitrault littéraire pour la
chose et donc emblématique et cette loi
là si importante dans laquelle le
gouvernement joue sa crédibilité et
peut-être sa survie cette loi là le
président de la république n'a jamais
bien
devant les français c'est une loi très
importante et est très importante dans
sa première mouture dans la les
intentions qui étaient les siennes
puisque c'était une loi qui affirmait
que l'assouplissement du droit du
travail était une condition pour que des
emplois se créent
ça c'est en allemand et en audition il a
fait cette question sans fin il
il a beaucoup sur ce sujet il n'a pas
assumé vous pouvez pas citer une phrase
vous qui êtes un observateur attentif
pour ne pas citer une phrase qu'il est
dit sur ce sujet une phrase qui est fait
image et qui ce soit gravé dans l'esprit
des français
la ligne politique de françois hollande
il ne l'a su ou pas il ne l'a pas
assumer et c'est pourquoi il va se
trouver en très grave au défi qui est-ce
que vous considérez le 49-3 à l'arrière
pensée de manuel valls est ce qu'il ya
un ancien conseiller de myriam el khomri
ce matin dans les journaux c'est à dire
qu'ils vont faire semblant de discuter
puis qu'à un moment c'est ce qui va
arriver parce que ça ne passera pas
c'est pas une arrière pensée c'est une
nécessité
c'est à dire que ce enfin à aller de
recul en recul ce qui est jamais
impossible mais ils ne trouveront pas de
majorité pour ce texte les des comptes
qui ont été faits y compris par le
rapporteur sont des décomptes seul
incroyablement pessimistes puisque ils
manquent leur dire le droit
donc on va tout droit à un accident
parlementaire qui peut s'achever en
effet par un camp de trois ans les
contres soit sage en force justement ce
matin un sondage et la montre le trois
quarts des français sont contre cette
loi dans l'état actuel des choses
donc si on la passe en force avec les
trois quarts des français qui sont
compte la situation sociale joue pas
comment on peut s'améliorer mais la
situation sociale ne s'améliore pas
c'est une comment dirais-je c'est une
communication c'est un plan de
communication
d'ailleurs sans substance qui consista à
ceux à se multiplier les affirmations
autour de ce mantra qui dit ça va mieux
ça ne va pas mieux les français le
savent et plus on leur dit que ça va
mieux quand ils voient que ça n'est pas
le cas plus salée fâchent est ce que
vous considérez qu'alain juppé par
exemple c'est le point de vue d'un des
politologues et sondeurs qui
il a d'ores et déjà gagné la primaire
parce que son avance est trop
considérable pour que même une entrée en
campagne terrisse plantes de nicolas
sarkozy puisse permettre de remonter
guillaume durand je peux me tromper mais
ceux qui disent que les élections sont
joués à l'avance n'ont jamais vécu de
l'intérieur
aucune élection pas une primaire d'
alain juppé a une avance mais cette
avance est une avance qui peut
naturellement être remise en question au
fur et à mesure que l'on avance et il va
lui revenir ça n'est pas joué et il va
lui revenir
évidemment de porter et d'alimenter
l'espoir que beaucoup de français même
temps lui dont vous doit justement je
reviens à cette affaire des trois quarts
des français qui sont contre la loi
contre la loi travail dans son vin son
aspect évidemment d'aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est pas un problème pour les gens
la droite et du centre qui voulaient
toiletter la loi du fameux code du
travail qui voulait mettre une part de
libéralisme dans la société française
pour attraper nos voisins de se rendre
compte que finalement les français sont
tout à fait hostile à tout ça oui parce
qu'on ne leur parle pas parce qu'on ne
fait pas ce qu'on appelle la pédagogie
de désorientation que l'on prend parce
qu'on ne les défend pas parce qu'il n'y
a pas de leadership parce qu'on
s'adresse pas aux peuples des citoyens
comme à ceux qui en effet sont les
premiers concernés par ce qui va se
passer mais vous parlez de la loi moi je
vais vous dire deux choses simples il ya
une chose que j'approuve c'est qu'on
puisse avoir en effet des discussions à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise et que ces
discussions puissent changer la manière
dont on travaille ça c'est bien
je suis radicalement opposé radicalement
durement opposé à deux orientations la
première c'est qu'on surtaxe les
contrats à durée déterminée
je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui faire
les rennais fait les frais non ce qu'ils
doivent faire hurler tous les gens de
bon sens s'est pas uniquement le
patronat qui a du bon sens et c'est
jean quittait partout les gens c'est
dans le champ économique hills et ceux
pour qui il est important de trouver du
travail qui doivent hurler parce que je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui il y a près de
90% des contrats de travail signés qui
sont signés en cdd
si on veut les surtaxer et si on croit
que parce qu'on les surtaxes les autres
alors grand mélo gens créer des réseaux
fnac dont ils vont passer bien ça prouve
une fois de plus qu'il y à une partie de
la gauche qui n'a pas les yeux en face
des trous du point de vue du travail qui
ne gêne eux qui ne ressent pas les choix
de l'entreprise ça c'est la première
raison pour laquelle je suis
radicalement opposé je trouve que c'est
anti économique et anti emploi et la
deuxième raison je suis opposé au fait
que l'on baisse de tarif qu'on baisse le
le ce que rapportent les heures
supplémentaires parce que je pense qu'on
doit payer le travail et que l'idée
selon laquelle est bien au fond une
heure supplémentaire on va on va faire
en sorte qu'elle ne rapporte pas aux
salariés l'effort qui va y mettre et une
idée que je combats si j'étais nicolas
sarkozy ce sourire et en vous entendant
défend les heures supplémentaires eh bah
écoutez c'est peut-être parce que vous
n'avez pas suivi les campagnes
électorales nombreuses que nous avons
faite sur ce sujet ici un point sur
lequel j'ai j'ai été un plutôt proche de
nicolas sarkozy c'est celui des heures
supplémentaires ma seule différence
c'est que je propose qu'on en abaisse le
coût en amputant la prime 1 sur les
charges que les heures supplémentaires
paix avant qu'on termine sur l'école
parce que je sais que ça vous tient à
coeur j'aurais quand même qu'on donne on
qu'on dise un mot sur les propos assez
durs ça touche beaucoup les français
aussi ballan dans les deux sens un des
manuels macron à l'égard du salaire de
carlos ghosn il est en train carrément
de le menacer des gis ferrer est ce
qu'il faut faire une loi sur la
rémunération des grands patrons du
service que je ne sais pas s'il faut
faire une loi mais quand un salaire
devient indécent outrepasse la limite
qui devrait être celle du bon sens et au
fond de la décence que l'on doit dans
une période de crise je pense qu'il est
nécessaire de le dire je veux rappeler
que l'assemblée générale rezaï ou de le
faire deleu
d'en prendre acte je rappelle que
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires a
refusé cette augmentation de salaire et
que naturellement c'est le conseil
d'administration où siègent beaucoup de
gens qu'on a choisi qui sont allés dans
le sens de cette augmentation et je
trouve ça extrêmement choquant et c'est
qu'ils nous et qui nous écoutent sont
choquants tous ceux qui s'y opposent ont
raison la dernière question concerne
effectivement éducation tout à l'heure
vous expliquer le champ de ruines
d'après vous qu'est l'éducation
nationale mais quel est le problème
majeur qui est posée puisque finalement
françois hollande comme madame belgacem
eux aussi font le constat de leur point
de vue que ça va beaucoup mieux car elle
est ce qu'on peut donner pour terminer
cet entretien un exemple bon après vous
beaucoup d'enseignants vous écoute et je
vous assure que en nous entendant ou en
entendant cette phrase de françois
hollande
ils font des bons parce que la situation
elle est profondément dégradée est plus
dégradée encore le sentiment que les
enseignants ont que on se moque d'eux la
réforme du collège qui est une qui est
une atteinte profonde non pas seulement
1 à ce qu'ils font comme exercice
professionnel mais une atteinte profonde
à leur métier une atteinte profonde à ce
qu'ils sont cette réforme du collège on
annonce que naturellement ne touchera
tandis même qu'aucun ministres
successifs et moi je dis qu'il y a là un
enjeu majeur de l'avenir et que
l'alternance doit être en même temps le
signal de départ de la suppression de la
réforme du collège de d'une
reconstruction à partir de la base de ce
que doit être l'éducation nationale de
ce que tout ce qui doit se passer dans
les classes
c'est à dire avant tout une transmission
de connaissances 1 1 un soutien à
l'épanouissement des élèves mais une
transmission de connaissances pour que
on ait le sentiment que à l'école en
reçoit quelque chose et que quand on est
enseignant donne quelque chose et que en
sorte de c2c foutaise que son
et vous savez soi-disant enseignements
pluridisciplinaires à l'intérieur de
laquelle on suggère qu'il faut étudier
pendant trois mois
l'électrocution de claude françois dans
annonce à ce que vous voyez bien que
tout va dans ce sens
au lieu d'avoir des enseignements solide
on a du chewing gum du chewing-gum à
plusieurs
eh bien ce n'est pas mâcher du chewing
gum a plusieurs qui peut faire avancer
l'éducation nationale merci françois
baroin est revenu ce matin sur l'antenne
de radio classique donc pour défendre
notre point de vue à la fois sur
l'éducation nationale et sur la
situation politique bonne journée à vous
nous avons rendez vous avec la revue de
presse le rappel des titres sur
l'antenne de radio classique paris
première